I want to recommend just a fantastic
documentary called holy hell it's a
documentary about uh will Allen's
experiences as a member of a cult called
the buddhafield cult and the cult leader
is a guy who initially went by the name
Michel but later went by a different
name Will Allen the filmmaker was the
official filmmaker of the cult so unlike
with many of these cult documentaries
you have tons of video of both the cult
leader and what went on in the cult it
is endlessly fascinating and I don't
want to give away sort of the things
that happen in the documentary but there
is just an unbelievable sort of climax
to the storyline at the end of this it
is available on netflix you can also uh
get this on amazon and you can find this
and all of our other recommendations at
david pakman.com slash recommendations I
know you haven't seen this yet Pat but
did it you have to see this documentary
I'm pretty fascinated with cults in
Colliers so I'm sure I'm gonna have to
check it out earlier this week we spoke
and read summers from what some describe
as a call to other the described a sort
of a spiritual movement and others
described as just a a message from God
and and and uh we we spoke to read
summers earlier this week holy hell is
the documentary it's on Netflix it's on
amazon check it out along with my other
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations will take a break
what a show we have for you today